hello everyone my name is Salman Kotani
and I'm an associate professor of
bioengineering at the University of
Illinois at Chicago and today I'm going
to tell you about
microfabricated human liver tissues for
drug development so before we start with
these sort of micro fabricated tissues
let me set the stage for why we need
liver tissues so drug-induced liver
injury is a huge problem for
pharmaceutical drug attrition it's an
easy leading cause of preclinical and
clinical years it's a leading cause of
post-market drug withdrawals and it
causes approximately 50% of acute liver
failure in the US alone all in all Dilli
drug-induced liver injury has been
linked to approximately thousand
marketed drugs and so generally before
drug makes it to clinical trials its
tested on animals for adverse effects as
well as beneficial effects unfortunately
when it comes to the liver animal
studies are typically not fully
predictive of human outcomes and so over
the last 20 years or so pharmaceutical
companies have started using in vitro
cultures of human hepatocytes so human
about asides
are the major cell type in the liver
they constitute approximately 70% of the
liver there's other cell types as well
in the liver that I'll discuss later on
but for the most part these human ibadah
sites are cultured in vitro in a dish
and some level of drug testing is done
on these cells however while this sounds
good in theory in practice these
hepatocytes very rapidly lose their
phenotypic functions so here I'm showing
hepatocyte that are cultured on collagen
coded tissue culture plastic and you can
see on the left that very rapidly the
function of these cells here I'm showing
one function albumin secretion 500-plus
functions but this is a good marker and
you can see that that function declines
very rapidly in these two-dimensional
conventional mono cultures furthermore
after a couple weeks even the cells that
are alive as you can see on the bottom
right look no longer like a hepatocyte
like it should like on the top right and
so overall this issue is a problem in
the pharmaceutical community and what
happens is that most investigators try
to do their drug testing in the first
couple days of these cultures when
they're still viable and liver like
however that doesn't represent what
happens in the clinic in the clinic
people are taking drugs over not just a
couple days but weeks and years and so
the idea is to try to mitigate this
issue and to create hepatocyte cultures
that essentially isolate and so if one
were to one or two think about that
problem how would one go about
addressing it well if you think about it
most organs in the body including the
liver have a very complex micro
environment so this micro environment
that hepatocyte are subjected to
contains other herbicides that have beta
sites bind to and form channels between
the cells the hepatocytes are sitting on
a complex extracellular matrix they're
interacting with other cell types in the
liver for instance endothelial cells
stellate cells etc there is flow of
blood in the liver that causes various
gradients of oxygen and other nutrients
and hormones so these are all things
that if you sort of think about it are
not being replicated adequately in these
two-dimensional dying cultures that I
showed you in the previous slide and so
over the last 15 years or so people have
started investigators have started
determining how do we go about designing
the micro environment around the
parasites in vitro in a dish such that
we can have precise control over some of
these factors and so this is where
engineering comes in so people have
utilized engineering tools adapted from
the semiconductor industry for instance
so the same tools that are used to
create computer chips are the same tools
that people have utilized to design the
micro environment around her parasites
and other kinds of cells as well
to try to not have that problem occur
which I showed you in the previous slide
and so there's a variety of different
different models available to
pharmaceutical scientists ranging from
microsomes which are essentially
fractions of cells and not actually
living cells all the way to liver slices
so liver slices is the basically you
take a liver you slice it and do thin
slices like a deli slicer and then these
slices are most physiologically relevant
they retain the architecture of the
liver there are basically mini livers
however those slices don't survive more
than a couple days you're slicing the
liver you're cutting it cells don't like
that and so there's a gap between these
plated monolayer hepatocytes that
decline very quickly in liver slices in
the sense that liver slices are very
physiological but don't last very long
in these monitors so the parasites also
don't last very long so this gap the
community of academic and pharmaceutical
investigators has tried to fill with
these engineered liver models now what
are these engineered liver models now in
the marketplace over the last 10 years a
variety of different engineering liver
models are now available these are
three-dimensional spheroids bioprinted
liver tissue news piranhas chip which
are essentially little microfluidic flow
devices and then what are called micro
pattern co-cultures now due to time
constraints I'm not gonna go in through
most of these models and their nuances I
encourage you to look at some of my
publications on my website or email me
afterwards but today I'm going to talk
about the model system that we utilize
in my lab which is called the micro
pattern co-cultures or MPC C's now let
me asourian to do this model because
you'll be hearing about it a lot over
the next 10 20 minutes and so micro
pattern co-cultures the idea is very
straightforward the idea is that you
take primary human hepatocytes and you
organize them in a dimension that's
desirable so for instance here we find
that circles of a certain dimension tend
to be pretty good for a sites it allows
the bat asides to make interactions with
each other these circles tend to stay
put we can track them over time and then
what we do is we surround these
besides circles with the second cell
type called a 3d 3j2 mirroring embryonic
fibroblast it's a mouse fibroblast
derived from the embryo mouse embryo
that seems to help humans and helps in
the sense that it doesn't cause that
decline of hepatocyte function that I
showed you in the previous slide now the
natural question that comes up is well
what should be the diameter of the
hepatocyte colony how far should they be
spaced well on the left hand side we did
some optimization where if you look at
the black bars they're basically random
co-cultures of these cell types so
there's basically no architecture no
organization these cells are randomly
distributed on a surface as soon as we
start patterning the imager that
essentially the next three sets of bars
you can see that we get a tremendous
boost in liver function so here I'm
showing actually two liver functions one
is albumin secretion which is a protein
that delivers secretes to maintain the
osmotic pressure and blood and the
others urea secretion which is
essentially nitrogen metabolism to
detoxify ammonia that's toxic and so you
can see that the pattern cultures tend
to function much higher than the random
co-cultures now what are those numbers
the pattern numbers well the first
number so for instance 36 means that's
the diameter colony the colony colonies
diameter the second number 9b refers to
the center to Center spacing between the
colonies and so you can see that as the
colonies get bigger you can see 490
microns about half a millimeter sized
colonies you can see that the function
is optimal at that size and so on the
right hand side all the pictures that
you're seeing are essentially that
optimal colony size of half a millimeter
approximately 490 micron 500 micron
which is half a millimeter diameter and
then space 1200 micron apart so that's
what the current model of micro pattern
co-cultures is and you can see the
hepatocyte if you're not used to looking
at a fantasise those are parasites look
pretty good in terms of morphology they
form these green bile canaliculi in
between them so they're basically
polarized they're able to secrete this
bile
like analog into channels between them
that's what the green is and then we can
pattern these we can create these mvcc's
in a standard multi-well plate for drug
screening which is really important
because pharmaceutical companies have
massive amounts of infrastructure to
handle place and so the fact that we can
do these mvcc's in plates allows
pharmaceutical companies to very easily
screen drunks up we can do 96 well plate
which is shown here we can do 24 well
plate 6 well plates 384 plates you name
it
and you can see that the patterning is
very consistent if you look at the
bottom pictures on the right you can see
that we get very reproducible patterning
which is where the engineering tools
come in so in addition to having higher
function with these MPC C's you can see
that now the functions of the liver
don't decline very rapidly so in
two-dimensional monolayers I showed you
before that those functions go down very
rapidly now in this MPC see if anything
that some of the functions actually
increase and then stabilize for about
four weeks in vitro now these are two
functions of the liver most
pharmaceutical companies care about drug
metabolism capacity and so what we're
showing here are essentially what we do
is we give the cells a specific drug and
then we let the cell metabolize that
drug into a metabolite by-product into
that by-product as a marker of an
enzymatic reaction that the cells should
be doing and so you can see that all of
these metabolites that we're measuring
are detected in the supernatant of the
cell culture suggesting that those
enzymes are active in the cells and so
overall what we find is that all these
functions that pharmaceutical companies
care about seem to be active and stable
for about four weeks or so in these MPC
C's now you can imagine that right now
the MPC C's lasts for about four weeks
how can we go about increasing the
lifetime of these cultures and so we
recently discovered a very interesting
protocol where what we knew is that
every week or so we starve the culture
for about two days so this is sort of
this intermittent starvation that has
gotten a lot of attention for weight
loss and so turns out that if we apply a
similar protocol to our cultures where
every week so we give them five days of
serum and hormones and then every week
for two days we starve them of that
serum and hormones and we do that on a
weekly interval and you can see that
what happens is that these cells
actually remain a live molar so the same
kind of intermittent starvation
intermittent fasting that people apply
for weight loss it turns out also
benefits liver cultures in vitro so what
I'm showing here in the pictures is that
the starved cultures maintain the size
of the hepatocyte island that's depicted
in the white circles whereas the
non-star cultures on the bottom left
over time they shrink and obviously as
they shrink the cells die off and on the
right-hand side bottom right hand side
is just quantification of the island
diameter and you can see that it's much
better retained in the starved cultures
compared to the non star cultures so
that's wonderful that the cells are
retained but what about function well we
see the same kind of thing that because
the hepatocytes are better retained on
the island with starvation intermittent
starvation you can see the functionality
so I'm showing albumin secretion on the
Left top-left urea secretion on the top
right and then on the bottom left I'm
showing those green bile canaliculi
channels that I that I mentioned before
and you can see that across the board
the starved cultures maintain these
function for a long time so now instead
of the cells only lasting 3 to 4 weeks
we're able to get these cells to survive
and function with this starvation
protocol for six plus weeks so this was
quite a good finding and it's a simple
protocol and we just recently published
it in toxicological sciences so of
course primary cells are are the most
physiologically relevant cell type but
ultimately there are limited resources
there's only so many organs to go around
there's only so many cells available so
what we have done is we have adapted
this technology this MPC C
nology do IES derive human about a site
so if you're not familiar with IPS
technology it basically is the idea that
you can take any cell of the body
converted to an induced pluripotent stem
cell and then re differentiate it into a
differentiated cell like the hepatocyte
or neuron what not and so it provides an
unlimited resource of cells and most
importantly it provides a patient
specific resource of cells because now
anybody cells let's say skin cell can be
taken converted to IPS ES and then re
differentiate it into a parasite or
other kinds of cells so it turns out
that if you take these IPS drive the
parasites we're gonna call them I haves
and if you put them in the MP CC system
you essentially get the same kind of
boost and function so if you compare if
you look at the left hand side you look
at our blooming secretion again one of
the functions of the liver you can see
that the InP CC is able to boost albumin
secretion in these ihab's at
significantly higher levels then if you
don't have the MP CC and just have a
conventional two-dimensional monoculture
of these cells and those tend to decline
on the right-hand side you have again
enzymatic activity drug metabolism
enzymatic activity and you can see that
the InP cc's are much more active when
it comes to this major enzyme then a
conventional two-dimensional monoculture
so essentially whether you use primary
cells or ihab's
the MPC C technology is able to handle
both and boost their functions now
that's the introduction to the model the
question is was it what is it good for
in pharmaceutical practice well I sort
of alluded to this problem of
drug-induced liver injury and that
obviously is a major concern that's
safety if you think about liver injury
that's essentially a safety question and
that's on the bottom so within safety
there's many different things people
look at and they look at you an
expression profiling they look at high
content imaging etc the details are not
so important except that safety is a
major use of these models well there's
two other uses of liver models on the
left-hand side you have drug
pharmacokinetics this is the idea that
if you take a drug how long will it last
in the body how quickly will it be
removed from the body these are
questions that need to be addressed and
liver often is a rate limiting organ in
drug metabolism and pharmacokinetics on
the right hand side you have efficacy so
there are several liver diseases out
there or diseases that affect the liver
for instance diabetes hepatitis B and
seen infection virus infection malaria
etc and liver models are being used to
develop novel drugs against these
diseases so the idea is that a platform
like the MVCC could theoretically be
used for all three areas where from
suitable scientists could depending on
their needs apply the model to either
VMDK efficacy or safety so what I'm
gonna do over the next few slides is
show you some examples of some of these
areas just to give you a sort of flavor
of how this model system has been
utilized to mitigate issues in drug
development so let's talk about toxicity
this is something that most people can
relate to you know you take a drug you
have an adverse reaction and obviously
that's not a good thing and these sort
of adverse reactions need to be
predicted before a drug enter the
marketplace so let me give you an
example of a very dramatic drug so this
drug called failure ad it basically was
heralded as a cure for hepatitis B virus
infection so hepatitis B virus infects
250 plus million people in this world
there's a vaccine but once you get it
there's no cure drugs are not curative
this drug you know 20 30 years ago was
heralded as a cure for HPV however
unfortunately when it went into phase 1
clinical trials five people died after
taking this drug and it took about two
weeks for those people to die and so
clearly the FDA was not too happy with
that they came and they stopped the
trial and they this drug has never seen
the light of day since that time and so
it was a huge loss for humans because
drug that supposed to that was supposed
to cure HPV now is also severely toxic
and so about 12 years ago or so Alan
Lanham pharmaceutical company Al Anam
pharmaceuticals which is a company in
Boston came to us and they wanted to
develop a new file URI that would not be
toxic but still retain its positive
effects on hepatitis B however obviously
that they cannot use animals for this
because none of the animal species that
were tested showed this toxicity this
was a human specific toxicity so they
needed a human relevant model so they
came to us we tested this drug on our
mvcc's and we found the punchline is
that they found that indeed it was
severely toxic to human hepatocyte but
only in a long-term and stable model
like the MPC C so let me walk you
through this data so on the right hand
side rightmost is failure early it's
also goes by five i odo to pine flora
arabinose yearning that's failure T then
you can see that as we give the cells
more and more drug it is severely toxic
the dotted blue line indicates no
toxicity anything lower than that is
toxicity and so you can see that failure
team is severely toxic to the cells all
the other drugs to the left of failure
18 are essentially analogs of failure
learning they're not quite failure
learning but people have sort of
modified certain parts of failure day to
see what would happen and none of those
drugs are asked toxic as file yearning
and so you can imagine that this is just
a proof of concept where now you can
begin to think about developing drugs
that might not be as toxic at file as
failure early but still retain their
positive effects
well is this a human specific finding at
least in clinical trials compared to
preclinical species that were tested it
seemed to indicate that this is a human
specific finding would we find the same
thing in vitro and the answer is yes
when we test this when we do that exact
same experiment I just described to you
on rat mvcc's so MPC C is formed with
rat hepatocytes we do not see any
toxicity and so this is a classic
example that you absolutely need a human
liver model to detect the toxicity of
failure dean because the animal species
especially roaring which is very popular
for pharmaceutical drug testing would
not have suffice
well it turns out that if this is a very
severely toxic drug it turns out if you
take other severely toxic drugs so for
instance amiodarone
braum Finnick etc these are all drugs
that either have been withdrawn from the
market or have boxed warnings on them
which basically says big liver warning
and it turns out that when these drugs
are tested on MPC C's on at least two
donors of hepatocyte we get 100%
sensitivity which means that there's no
reason that a severely toxic drug should
ever be given to humans live humans I
should say because those drugs now can
be screened now using systems like MPC
C's and other platforms so this is a
great advance in the field both for my
work as well as other people's work that
now severely toxic drugs should be
screened out a pharmaceutical
development before they hit live humans
while it turns out that not all drugs
are severely toxic so some drugs may be
toxic to some people but not others they
may have varying degrees of toxicity
depending on how much you take the drug
and so what if you look at a broader set
of drugs so what we did is we selected
3637 liver toxic drugs from the FDA
database
these are drugs that have varying levels
of liver toxicity they're not all
severely toxic we selected ten non toxic
drugs we gave the cells six days of
treatment with these drugs up to a doses
that were 100-fold what is found in the
plasma which is reasonable in the field
and what we did then is we measured
liver functions like albuminuria and we
also looked at cytotoxicity markers like
ATP and if a drug caused reduction in
any of these markers such as albumin
urea and ATP by at least 50 percent so
it basically means this you know 50
percent of the cells either died or 100
percent of the cells experience 50
percent dysfunction either way if we saw
50 percent reduction in these markers we
call that drug pocket and if we didn't
we call that drug non-toxic and so and
then you collated all these results and
this is what we found we found that when
it costs 2 cents
activity so sensitivities define us how
many toxic drugs can you correctly call
toxic so obviously if you have 100%
sensitivity you called all 37 drugs
toxic and we have a wonderful model most
models are not completely accurate so
you have some level of of false
negatives and so when it comes to
sensitivity you can see that the
sandwich cultured human about a set schh
which is this conventional monolayer to
be monolayer is not very sensitive so it
misses you know almost 60 70 percent of
the toxic drugs it's only calling about
30 to 40 percent drugs toxic when it
comes to the MPC C's with primary human
about aside so PHH mvcc's we are getting
a boost of sensitivity to about 70% so
which is to twofold higher than the
conventional monolayer and if you do the
same testing on I MPC sees with the I
have Steve's or the sustainable cell
source you're getting pretty close to
the pH H when it comes to specificity
specificity implies how many of the
non-toxic drugs did you call falsely
toxic so we certainly don't want to kill
a good tough a good drug we certainly
don't want to just you know eliminate a
good drug from the pipeline so it's very
important that the specificity is as
close to 100% as possible because we
want non-toxic drugs to be called
non-toxic and here you can see that all
three models have actually very good
specificity so one doesn't have to worry
about killing the next billion-dollar
drug one just has to worry about making
sure that a drug that's severely toxic
doesn't make it to humans and causes all
kinds of lawsuits and waste of money
now drug induced liver injury is one
application of liver models the other
application is hepatitis B infection and
I can already oriented you to hepatitis
B infection and as I said to you before
hepatitis B hepatitis B is a disease
that only infects non-human primates and
humans so chimpanzees for instance and
humans
it doesn't infect rodents and it infects
only parasites in the liver and so
people can do testing on chimpanzees
because it's too cost-prohibitive it's
restricted it's actually prohibited in
Europe restricted in the you
yes and so you need an in vitro human
model of HPV infection that could be
used to develop novel drugs because
currently the drugs that are available
for a hepatitis B are not fully curative
and so turns out when we put hepatitis B
on to our cultures were able to detect
viral antigens in the culture of
supernatants for several weeks let me
explain how this works first so what we
do is we take live virus we put it on
the cultures the cultures take up the
virus they start replicating the virus
as happens in the body and then they
shed viral proteins in the supernatant
and we detect those viral proteins as a
sign that the virus is replicating okay
so one of the viral proteins that we
detect in the supernatant is called HPV
en didja antigen just implies protein
and so you can see that both the I M PCC
with the ihab's and the M PCC with the
primary hepatocyte both are showing the
shed antigen in the media suggesting
that the virus is replicated and they're
both doing in a very similar efficiency
over time if anything the inbc C's
slightly worse at higher time points
compared to n PCC but on average both
are pretty good so this model shows
chronic infection with hepatitis B virus
over several weeks well it turns out
that not only does it show infection
over several weeks
it shows higher levels of infection than
the conventional models so what I'm
showing here are three conventional
models one is a conventional model or a
two-dimensional model or you can get
that infected you can see that the Shedd
antigen is pretty low in the ICC model
so conventional confluent monolayers of
ihab's in the IR CC which are random
co-cultures of I have so no patterning
as I kind of mentioned before there is
infection but it's low only in the InP
CC where you have patterning and
co-culture do you have this high level
of infection now in terms are but not
only do you have high level of infection
for a couple weeks this infection lasts
for almost 30 days so here I'm showing
this Enda jeanette shed which indicates
the
is replicating and you can see compared
to mark which is that dotted line mark
just means that there's no infection so
whatever the signal is essentially
background and you can see that compared
to mark you actually have detectable
infection out for almost 30 days and it
turns out that if you notice that the e
antigen is sort of declining over time
so even though the cells are infected
they are losing some of the infection
over time and that correlates with cell
functions so if you look at albumin
secretion on the bottom right you can
see that albumin is also declining so I
guess the point I'm trying to make here
is that in the future if we can keep
cell function high we can also likely
keep infection higher and that's
something we're working towards in my
lab well you have a model of infection
what is it good it's testing max at
least one aspect of it so we selected
two drugs that are currently in the
clinic they're both they inhibit the
reverse transcription of Moral mRNA so
that the virus cannot fully package and
be shipped from the cell and those two
drugs are in taco Baer and Tanaka where
and then we also tested body's natural
defenses these cytokines called
interferon alpha and beta to see if they
would reduce infection and it turns out
indeed Billu so if you take the MSO DMS
is basically no drug it's basically just
an organic solvent you don't get much
reduction in HPV DNA so this is DNA off
the virus both inside the cell and
outside the cell intracellular
extracellular if we put on an toxaemia
on the cell you can see that that DNA is
severely reduced which is a good thing
if we put two Natha where you can see
that well the intercellular DNA is not
reduced much but the extracellular DNA
is reviews and then if you put
interferon which is body's natural
defense you can see that that also has
an effect on reducing DNA so this is a
proof of concept that the system is
amenable to using this these sort of
drugs the figure out which drugs are
gonna be more effective and this all
happens without compromising cell
function so this is not a situation
where the cells are not replicating
virus because they're dying
due to the drug as you can see albumin
secretion is Pro fairly stable across
all the drug treatment suggesting that
the cells are viable but the drug is
having a specific effect on the virus
replication and secretion which is a
good thing because we don't want virus
constantly in our blood the other
disease that my lab works on with
respect to these model systems is
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease so
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease is a
huge issue almost 33% of us people in
the US have fatty liver it typically
goes hand-in-hand with with obesity
people who are obese also tend to have
fatty liver which what happens as the
liver starts accumulating fast those are
those white bubbles that you're seeing
in the top-left picture and what happens
is that this is a risk factor for
diabetes it's a risk factor for scarring
of the liver called fibrosis and
hepatocyte s-- alone are not sufficient
to model this disease you need another
cell type of the liver called the
hepatic stellate cell and hepatic
stellate cell is important because it
causes that fibrosis of the liver so the
question is you know this is a disease
that has no cure pharmaceutical
companies are very interested in
developing a cure the question is can be
mimicked aspects of this disease in
vitro so the first thing we looked at is
well can we meet the cultures fatty just
like people who have obesity their
livers become fatty can we make them
fatty so we did a very simple trip we
fed the cultures high levels of glucose
and so if you feed them very low glucose
or hypoglycemia you don't get much fat
so the white circle indicates the
hepatocyte and the green indicates fat
accumulating in the liver if you give
them normal amounts of glucose you get a
little bit of fat which is normal and
then if you give it too much glucose
like in diabetes you get tons of fat
accumulation those green drops that are
forming well it turns out not only do
the parasites and mvcc's become fatty as
they should if you feed them too much
energy too much food they also become
insulin resistant just like in diabetes
so let me explain to you what this is on
the left hand side what we're doing is
we're taking the normal glycemic culture
so a little bit of fat
not a lot and we're giving those
cultures lactate and pyruvate substrates
OS we're calling it as and what the
liver does is that it takes those
substrates and produces glucose this is
liver special quality that if you're
starving the liver can produce its own
glucose if you give it insulin what
insulin should do is block glucose
production insulin is basically your
body saying you're full stop producing
glucose I have enough blood sugar and so
you can see that insulin down regulates
that glucose production from the liver
and if you give too much insulin the
glucose production is completely knocked
out on the left hand side but in the
hyperglycemic cultures they are fatty so
the picture I showed you in the previous
slide you can see that that insulin
response is severely blunted you can see
that you don't get the same level of
insulin response which is essentially
the definite it's one resistance so
we're not only getting fatty cultures or
we're getting in cylinders and cultures
but as I alluded to before we need this
other cell type of the liver called the
hepatic stellate cell this is the cell
type that gets activated it becomes the
fibroblast it starts depositing collagen
and starts causing scarring of the liver
so we incorporated these hepatic
stellate cells into our MPC C's and you
can see that the basic hepatic functions
were not compromised on the bottom left
and on the bottom right you can see that
these red stem cells which are positive
for alpha smooth muscle actin and
they're activated are interacting with
the green hepatocyte it's very nicely in
this model well so we have this model is
it mimicking this non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease and it turns out it is and
so first thing we notice is that these
cells are the positive culture so the
green that's basically near the red
indicates that these cells are
depositing collagen just like in liver
fibrosis so that's one hallmark of
disease the second thing we noticed is
that that drug metabolism activity that
I've been kind of mentioning over in my
slide deck which is critical for the
cells to metabolize drugs that drug
metabolism capacity is severely down
regulated when hepatic stellate cells
are present in culture so if you add one
point two five thousand or two
5,000 or 5,000 agencies in Vermont you
get a severe reduction in drug
metabolism capacity which is a huge
problem if people are taking drugs
because those drugs are not gonna get
properly metabolize furthermore when we
add these HSCs to our culture you can
see that they the cells start losing
these bowel canaliculi those green
channels that I mentioned which is also
a problem when it comes to drug
metabolism well we have a disease
phenotype so the question is can be
treated it turns out that if we take two
drugs that are currently in clinical
trials or have been in clinical trials
and we put them on our culture as we can
see that one drug rescues the drug
metabolism capacity so the dotted line
indicates complete drug metabolism
available and then you try to get closer
to it to try to recover that and you can
see that the gkt drug rescues the 3:4
activity as close to dotted line but the
OCA drug will be the colic acid doesn't
do the same thing and then the
combination is as good as you get T
alone so one drug works for this but the
other doesn't what about the other
things we saw so if you remember those
those green channels that began to
disappear you can see that gkt drug
doesn't really do much for the green
channels but the open colic acid begins
to recover those green channels and then
the combination is somewhere in between
so basically the message here is that
the combination of drugs is critical to
recover some of those issues that the
liver cells were experiencing in this
natholi like fibrotic environment
meaning gkt does a good job for
recovering the drug metabolism activity
but then OCA does a good job of
recovering the bile canaliculi of the
cells so just showing you a proof of
concept of drug testing in this well it
turns out that we can also augment our
mvcc's with Cupra macrophages which are
a macrophage cell line we don't see much
loss of liver function but we can
stimulate the macrophages with something
like il-6 and they I'm sorry we can
stimulate it with LPS lipopolysaccharide
and the macrophages respond by secreting
inflammatory cytokines like il-6 and the
macrophages can figure
toes threatened by a particle just
showing that we can actually add goop
for macrophages to the system and still
have those macrophages alive
well now what we can do is we can create
sort of an our normal model or an
inflamed model of the liver the normal
model with the right ratio of
hepatocytes to macrophages and then the
inflamed model with more macrophages and
lipeh polysaccharide which is a
bacterial endotoxin that inflames the
liver and then we can ask the question
well how is drug toxicity affected when
you have a normal model or an inflamed
model and it turns out that if you have
inflammation in the liver certain toxins
will have more of a toxic effect on the
liver then if the liver is inflamed
then when deliver its normals on the
left hand side these are toxins that the
lower bar means more toxicity and you
can see that in the inflamed liver these
drugs are more toxic than in the normal
liver that we created on the on the
right hand side or non toxins which
don't really care if the liver is normal
or inflamed because they're not really
toxic to the liver so it turns out we
have taken this NPC C and we have now
put it under a flow device a
microfluidic chip so here you see an NPC
C that's been completely enclosed
we can now profuse it with media and
this is really important for essentially
connecting MPC C's the liver model to
other organ types like for instance
cancer or the heart etc this is sort of
this idea of a human on a chip that now
that we have this MPC C fully enclosed
in a flow device we can now connect it
with other organs and it turns out that
we can incorporate and opilio cells in
this flow and the endothelial some pain
their phenotype so this is basically a
more holistic model of the liver that
now incorporates endothelial cells and
it incorporates recirculating medium
just like it can imagine a heart pumping
the liver and then the blood going back
to the heart that's kind of the idea so
everything I've showed you with MPC C's
is at the end of the day still a
monolayer of cells is still a single
layer of cells and that layer of cells
obviously can go a long way I've shown
you so
many examples of how we can use a
monolayer of cells like mvcc's for a lot
of different applications but there are
certain things that that doesn't allow
us to do for instance one thing we can
do is look at three-dimensional changes
in cell cell interactions
three-dimensional changes in cell matrix
interactions in fibrosis and for that
you need a three-dimensional model and
when I say three-dimensional model I
mean a model that's several hundred
microns in the Z dimension not just XY
but in the Z dimension and so what we
have done is we have developed a
microfluidic device that allows us to
create these droplets these
three-dimensional droplets of cells in
collagen at the rate of 45,000 droplets
per hour so what happens is you have
collagen and hepatocyte solution coming
from the left oil coming at a t-junction
and then as both streams flow down the
obviously water and oil don't mix and
naturally this collagen forms these
droplets and what happens we do this at
4 degrees Celsius the collagen remains
unpolymerized we collect these droplets
we heat them up and as you may know the
collagen polymerizes when heated
trapping the cells and we get basically
these little droplets and these droplets
are three dimensional in nature there
are several hundred microns up to three
hundred microns we can create or more
and on the bottom you're just seeing
real pictures of the device the syringe
pumps that are feeding the flow streams
and then two devices on the right
running in parallel so we call these
micro tissues and what we did is we
compared these micro tissues to other
ways of creating three-dimensional
models so on the left hand side you have
these micro tissues put in these little
micro wells and B we have created these
fair waves which if you just see cells
without collagen they kind of aggravate
and in C we have essentially created
collagen with cells but no micro tissue
formation this is just a bulk gel we
just dispensed it into a play there is
no micro fluidics nothing and basically
all the data essentially indicates that
organizing the cells in three dimensions
using these droplets tends to lead to
higher liver functions than other
conventional tweety liver models and I
don't really
time to go into all the functions but if
you look across the board and you track
micro tissue over the other two models
you will see that they have higher liver
functions than otherwise now what we can
do is we can kind of create a
three-dimensional MVCC so we have this
droplet the Tabata site and then we can
surround it by fiberglass or whatever we
whatever we wish so it's essentially a
three-dimensional NPC see that instead
of having the NPC see on a plane now you
actually have a three-dimensional
droplet that's now surrounded by the
fiberglass and we can place them these
little wells and you can see the
fiberglass compact the collagen to
create these little droplets even
smaller than the hepatocyte only
droplets and it turns out this system is
even more stable than the MPC C system
I'm showing for functions of the liver
and you can see out to six weeks
this system keeps going and going and
going so if we adapt our core cultures
to now this three-dimensional micro
tissue model we're getting a more stable
and a higher functioning model for
longer term so I thank you for your
attention
there's a lot of people in my lab a lot
of great students and staff who do the
work and we're very blessed to be funded
by the National Institutes of Health
with great collaborators as well as a
National Science Foundation thank you